fall for me means friends family and fun
warmth and comfort food i think of like
a warm oven so it's more of a fuel
hi i'm kate hey i'm joaquin hi i'm
rollin and today we're making fall
inspired desserts using jello
[Music]
i picked the vanilla pudding i'm going
to attempt to make some caramel blondies
first thing i'm going to do is mix some
flour here baking powder cinnamon i'm
just going to whisk that together so
that it's well combined i'm going to
start off with my brown sugar the butter
and the secret ingredient jello here and
that's going to add some vanilla flavor
to this recipe and i'm just gonna
slowly combine all of this with my hand
mixer
fold in the caramel bits this really
just reminds me of gathering with my
family because during the holidays
we love to cook together we're gonna put
it in the oven and let it do its thing
all right so it's out of the oven now
and vanilla pudding replacement
definitely worked the consistency is
really moist i'm actually gonna decorate
it with caramel and white chocolate we
have actually some
leaf sprinkles here these little bits of
color just reinforce that it's fall so
here we have blondies with jello vanilla
pudding
[Music]
decided on chocolate pudding a nice
simple little thing that i like to call
ghosts in the graveyard i think i'd like
to do more of just a general fall spin
on it so we're gonna do little pumpkins
things like that first things first
we're gonna start with the pudding kind
of reminds me a lot of hot chocolate and
that also is kind of seasonally
appropriate my dad and i used to
have sort of a weekend tradition where
we would always make chocolate pudding
cool whip and with our spatula we're
just gonna add
the whole thing it is very
fluffy and light
crushed up sandwich cookies and we're
gonna add these in we'll grab our pan to
sort of start setting up our little
scene yeah it looks like dirt clearly it
doesn't taste like dirt why don't we
start with some fun little pumpkins i
think it's hard to hate chocolate
cookies and pudding
let's
call our dish the pumpkin patch
[Music]
i chose cherry jello and i'm going to be
making a cranberry pretzel square today
i think this is gonna be fall themed
because it reminds me of thanksgiving
here we have our crushed up pretzels
which i'm gonna go ahead and add to the
bowl
this is our butter just pour it right in
and now we're gonna add our sugar trusty
spatula easy to mix and it smells
amazing
use your hands get them a little dirty
and now we're going to throw it in the
oven next we are going to make cream
cheese filling i started picking up tips
and tricks of cooking from my mother and
my grandmother they were always like the
hosts now we're gonna get ready to make
our cherry cranberry jello topping we're
gonna pour in our hot water
put our cranberry
sauce in with our jello the hot water is
helping to dissolve the cranberry juice
pour it right on over
spread this out evenly
and then we're just gonna pop it right
in the fridge to finish cooling our
jello is jiggling at the top our
cranberry pretzel square i think people
are gonna love it
all right so these are blondie bars they
are cute they are really cool let's try
it you ready
that is really good
this is really moist it is here we have
our cherry cranberry pretzel salad
hmm whoa that's really good
[Music]
i like the tartness
i think it balances out how sweet
everything else is that's really tasty
you ready for mine the pumpkin patch
oh i got it i already went for it it
tastes delicious
i like with this one that you can like
kind of customize the bite like you can
pick up a piece of the candy corn or you
can go for the marshmallow or you can
combine
[Music]
you